[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar biosecurity for genome
engineering safety first and the seek
screen solution for functional
predictions i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by inscripta to learn
more visit them at inscripta.com
now we want to encourage you to
participate today by submitting as many
questions as you may want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
now this webinar is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our speakers today first dr beth
vitalis a biosecurity specialist at
inscripta
joining her is dr christa turnis a
bioinformatics specialist at signature
science
and finally dr todd triangan an
assistant professor of computer science
of the department of bioengineering at
rice university
beth kristen todd welcome you may now
begin your presentation
all right well thank you for this
opportunity today i want to thank
labrutz our collaborators at signature
science and rice university
my inscripta colleagues and and everyone
for their interest so today we will
address biosecurity for genome
engineering goals and challenges and the
power of working together and i'm happy
to be taking me here with christa
turners and tattering and who will
present a remarkable resource seek
screen that is providing a solution for
functional evaluation of engineered or
otherwise novel sequences
so what we hope you learned today
first why biosecurity is important for
everyone's safety and to safeguard
advanced bioengineering technologies
such as microbial genome engineering
second we will explain what is needed
for proactive biosecurity screening
practices to identify and help prevent
biorisk and as an example approach
outline and script is multi-prong
screening for our onyx microbe genome
engineering platform
third we will discuss challenges to
predict bio-risk and engineered
organisms
then kristin todd will describe a
computational screening platform that is
user-friendly open source available and
provides robust biological
characterization of input sequences
finally we will see seep screen
prediction come alive with a few real
world applications
so to start we recognize that genome
engineering capabilities are empowering
scientists to explore biology at an
extraordinary scale and now we can make
discoveries and drive impactful
innovation that will help improve human
health promote and expand sustainable
materials and fuels agriculture and food
supply
improve medical care and help meet other
pressing needs so there's tremendous
promise and excitement from mike in
microbial engineering
however as access and scale of
technology expands we must pay attention
and work together to respect and protect
the power
of all bioengineering technologies
okay so biosecurity protects everyone
well what do we mean by biosecurity so i
could condense into a definition here
biosecurity systems include procedures
intended to protect humans animals
plants and all organisms from being
harmed by biological agents
and these bioagents that may be a safety
threat are commonly microbes or toxins
we have lists of known bio risk causing
bugs and proteins
and but we also must consider novel
sorts of sources such as sars kobe 2.
for successful biosecurity some
questions we need to address how can bio
risk be introduced where might be coming
from and how do we identify potential
bio risk before it is a problem what
does it look like
so science is moving fast and
biosecurity must keep pace
all right so this first question how
might virus be introduced into synthetic
biology technology well there's two
major ways it may be deliberate an
individual or entity with nefarious
intent that bio-terror character that we
all fear the other major source is
inadvertent you know an accidental
event famous examples of such unforeseen
results in previous biological research
have been fatal to mice
so we are calling this inadvertent
source bio error it arises since biology
is complex then the outcomes of
biological
or bioengineering technologies
may be difficult to predict and also
synthetic biology technologies are
advancing scaling up
and rapidly diffusing to broad
populations increasing access so bio
risk may result from either mischief on
the left or mistake
so think for a moment which do you think
is a growing concern for the microbial
genome engineering
well while we need procedures
to block malicious use for advanced
high-throughput
throughput technology such as
democratized genome engineering bio
error is becoming a focal point
all right so let's go to that second
question
how do we recognize biorisk
it is important for all
researchers and get my slides catch up
with me to assess safety in their own
work and here i highlight a landmark
study by a national academy of science
committee in 2018. they laid out an
off-sited framework for evaluating risk
potential in new synthetic biology
technologies including microbial genome
engineering
and i want to note that this risk
evaluation framework was leveraged by an
engineering biology research consortium
sponsored and dhs funded malice analysis
workshop series in which inscripta
participated and we hope all industry
will take action to promote safety
culture
so the report highlighted drawbacks in
this current list based risk assessment
what an organism can do
is more important than what it is
and on a practical level sequence
screening needs to move beyond bad
microbe to sequence of concern as we'll
hear more later
all right so now that we've established
a need for biovirus prediction in
microbial genome engineering
as an example i will describe the
inscripta impetus and process for
proactive sequence screening for
engineering microbes
so the encrypted phonics platform i'll
describe in a nutshell allows for the
massive
parallel engineering of microbial
genomes so
to consider the number of variants that
can be rapidly engineered we scale up in
two dimensions the number of genome-wide
targets represented on the axis is
x-axis as well as the diverse edit types
sniffs in dells knockouts etc on the
y-axis
and and so this huge variation up to ten
thousand edits per library
enables enormous genotypic and thus
phenotypic variation
and the platform includes the instrument
the software and reagents it is all
optimized and accessible so customers
design their own genome-wide edits
and while we are excited about the power
this large-scale diversity generation
brings to genome discovery we're mindful
of the potential bio risk this could
introduce so in particular researchers
are now better able to explore
uncharacterized parts of genomes and we
consider complexity of genomic
interactions the potential of bioware
comes into view
and as a final note here in scripta
is committed to safe and responsible use
of this technology and we aim to help
ensure that this responsibility is held
up across the rapidly advancing genome
engineering industry
all right so safety first this customer
empowerment facilitates high impact
discoveries yet must be addressed in a
biosecurity system
so here's an overview of our multi-prong
proactive approach that addresses the
major ways bio risk may be introduced so
there's three major screening steps
shown here up a few more details on
following slides so first upcoming or
upfront customer screen to help prevent
the known bad actors
and we had trust approved customers so
this sequence screening
the second two prongs are primarily to
help prevent bio error
communication is key biosecurity
processes involve coordination across
groups adding scripta it's a
company-wide priority
and so our biosecurity perspectives
and practices are communicated with
customers and all are welcome to learn
more on our website
okay so first
we aim to block deliberate misuse of the
technology rare event it may be
devastating if it happens we follow
industry standard practices to screen
against government banned lists that
include individuals most likely to have
nefarious intent
trade.gov is a source
we anticipate virtually zero true
positives
and also point out that knowing your
customer comes in
in the event of a hidden sequence
screening follow-up protocols include
dialogue with customers as needed to
assess legitimate use
and although we do not
anticipate misuse customer screening is
essential for everyone as technology
reaches more and more people
right so let's look now at the
computational sequence greeting it's
carried out at two levels the input
genome and edit design libraries so we
have an insilico screen of customer
provided genomes as a first pass at bio
risk detection comparing against lists
of known bad genes and proteins
the second instillico screen is done on
all customer directed edits of very
large libraries and for this step we
sought a functional prediction rather
than a list-based approach
and that's where seek screen enters in
a functional bio-rich prediction
software but which we will all learn
more soon
and a biorisk alert on either level will
involve manual verification and if
oriented dialogue with customers as
mentioned on the previous slide to
discuss how to move forward safely
libraries passing the final screen will
go forward to manufacture and reagents
are shipped to happy customers
okay so point out that you see screen is
supported by the government agency iarpa
and you'll learn more soon it's it's
provided a solution for many of the
unscripted sequence screening needs that
we've encountered several of which we
believe are shared across the
bioengineering community
the software can handle
enormous plexity of our libraries we've
had 500 k plex library screen in less
than two hours uh variable size sequence
inputs um and it supports in-house
screening which is critical to ensure
confidentiality
seek screen will assign a function to
novel sequence variants to help predict
the biological input
and important for all industry is that
the cost of a screening system is not a
high barrier
to our knowledge
this seek screen is the only microbial
functional prediction for biosecurity
use cases that is open source
and descriptive values are long-standing
collaboration and ongoing interactions
with this extreme team
okay so i will end on
the note that security is a shared
responsibility community gathering
sparks collaboration
in late 2019 a few of us were addressing
the unique considerations for
biosecurity for genome engineering and
we had thoughts of you know let's start
getting folks together to chat and work
together to begin to solve the problems
we were facing
in particular sarah carter krista turnes
and i had some memorable visits at sun
bio beta that year which planted the
seed for such a focused gathering and
then soon in scripta was fortunate to
partner with megan palmer and catherine
brink of stanford university to
landscape and organize a virtual
workshop that was held last november
27 participants with diverse expertise
converged to initiate dialogue and
collaboration on industry practices
resources and opportunities for
microbial genome in engineering the
report is now published
on our website
and the key outcome is a desire for
inclusive dynamic
community
let's keep the dialogue going
and with that i will turn it over to
krista
thank you beth for giving that
introduction and mentioning seek screen
software i wanted to share some more
information about seek screen in case
anyone in the audience is interested in
downloading and running that locally on
your systems
at the bottom of this slide is the
website address where you can go and
identify more information about seek
screen on the wiki associated with the
get lab page
we have quite a bit of documentation
that'll explain how to download and run
the software
as well as what the different workflows
will output for you when you run seek
screen
we have three different modes in general
that you can use for seek screen the
first is called fast mode which is our
default mode so if you don't specify
what mode you'd like to run in you're
going to automatically go to fast mode
which will utilize diamond for
associating each sequence which is with
its most likely protein id and
functional annotations
the next option is sensitive mode
which will be as i suggest more
sensitive in its analysis but it can
also take more time because it uses
blast rather than diamond but sensitive
mode also comes with the additional
benefit of running many other tools
within our pipeline so
those are pictured here on the left
in green and you will get a number of
those tools output in intermediate files
so even though the outputs may not show
up in the final report there's lots of
goodies in there if you're interested in
any additional information about
functional annotations that you can get
with sensitive mode and the final mode
is ont mode
that's intended for analyzing long reads
or contigs
with fast and sensitive mode there's an
assumption that there's only one protein
coding sequence
per
analysis per read
whereas with ont mode we assume that
there are multiple open reading frames
within a read so when you look at your
outputs you'll have multiple lines of
output
with ont mode depending on how many open
reading frames are present within a read
whereas with fast and sensitive you'll
have one line of output per query
sequence
and we definitely encourage you to use
conda to install our software because
there are a number of different packages
that need to be installed for
dependencies
and we also have
instructions for how to run this locally
as docker singularity on our our wiki
page if you are not able to connect to
the internet on your local systems
so please take a look at our
documentation and try it out we'd love
to get your feedback on that
in general the seek screen final output
format comes in two different flavors
one is a computer friendly uh parsable
file that allows you to easily look at
things if you're going to be plugging
into the seek screen
outputs into a downstream pipeline that
you computationally want to analyze
further so that's a tsv file
the other output type is a
html report that you can interact with
so it's a point-and-click framework and
pictured here on this slide you can see
the alignment of one of the the
sequences
that was a query to the database hit
so lots of interesting interfaces that
you can
click on there and see if you want to
individually look at your sequence
outputs
the final thing i wanted to highlight as
far as running the software is that we
have added a number of different
flags that you can run with our software
that will modify the parameters or note
what tools you'd like to run in the
pipeline as optional additions
and you should do whatever works best
for you not everyone has the same exact
use case or research goal in running our
software and we've tried to include as
many options as possible to make this
workflow
customizable for for different end users
so please take a look at all the
different options that we have and think
about what makes the most sense for you
and scripta is a great example of using
c-screen because they've they've taken
certain portions of the output and plug
that into a larger pipeline that they
use for biosecurity
and that that's what beth was describing
earlier so we definitely encourage
everyone to use this and customize it
based on
your your workflows and use cases
so now moving past the logistics of how
to install and run the seek screen
software i wanted to talk a little bit
about
how
we put together the software what our
motivation was
and what kind of gaps we were trying to
fill at a high level in developing this
software and beth hit on this earlier
the the big idea was that we wanted to
move away from
simply classifying a sequence as
dangerous because it hit to
a pathogenic species of concern or if
you have a list of taxons of concern
and you screen your sequence against
that list it hits to a certain taxon
that's flagged as dangerous
well that is certainly beneficial and
there's a place for that and we're not
trying to replace
taxonomic analysis
we recognize that there are many open
source tools available to do taxonomic
classifications whereas there are not
very many open source tools available to
do
functional characterization of microbial
sequences especially when it comes to
biosecurity applications
so that was a gap that we were trying to
fill here
in in making sure that we were trying to
develop something that was going to be
of benefit to the community and we hope
that it is
if you're interested in reading more
about the motivation behind the
development of our software there are a
few
references to papers on the right on
this slide we encourage you to take a
look at those and read them after the
webinar
and i wanted to share an example just
for illustrative purposes of
how results would differ if you were
running a traditional dna screening
protocol for biosecurity purposes
against the biological select agents and
toxins list
or the bsat list compared to running our
seek screen software what different
outputs you would get
so pictured here in this table the first
four rows
passed the bsat screening protocol in
other words these particular sequences
were from proteins that were not on the
bsat list
however when they're analyzed with seek
screen you can see that they have some
functional potential that could be
damaging to the host specifically
they're capable of disabling organs
whereas the last two rows of this table
are sequences from proteins that are
similar
to the virus that causes smallpox so
they're they're from vaccinia so they're
not necessarily from that virus but they
have homology to it so that it does
raise a flag when you're running the
bsap pipeline
and
if you look at the actual function of
these sequences they aren't inherently
harmful by themselves so the first one
is involved in normal viral replication
processing the second sequence is
involved in the viron structure itself
so no
uh sequences of concern were assigned by
seek screen to these particular
sequences
and
again we feel like the information
provided by seek screen and the
functional characterization provided is
complementary to many of the other tools
people are using right now but it is
filling a gap and giving you that
functional information that can help
inform your biosecurity decisions
and
another thing i wanted to mention as we
were developing the software
there was a big gap that we noted in the
availability of customized labeling
or ontologies that could describe how
microbes can cause harm in a host
so we we spent a lot of time and there
is a paper linked at the bottom of this
slide by dr gene godbold on our team
who helped us to develop functions of
sequences of concern
which are customized labels that help
describe how a microbial sequence might
cause harm in a host and when we think
about computational solutions and
software having these standardized
labels to help describe why something
might be pathogenic is really critical
otherwise it's it's just a black box of
something via being assigned pathogenic
with no real understanding or
description of why
and so we really tried to make this
understandable and useful to end users
in the way that we catalog these
sequences
and integrated them into our software
i also wanted to mention that around the
time we were developing the functions of
sequences of concern
and seek screen software other groups
such as johns hopkins university applied
physics lab
was working on something called the
pathogenesis gene ontology or path go
which is conceptually very similar to
what we were doing with fun socks and we
benefited from collaborating with them
and working with them
on their path go ontology while we were
working through our funsock customized
labeling approach for seek screen
the pathco
is available and it's an ontology that
you can go to at github at the link at
the bottom of the slide if you're
interested there aren't currently any
annotations associated with that
ontology but we are hopeful that the
community will use this resource in the
future to help annotate sequences
and
please check that out another group that
we spoke with as we were developing the
functions of sequences of concern
was the gene ontology
multi-organism working group and these
are folks that have been working for a
long time on ontology problems and we've
benefited a lot from their expertise and
insights and how to
supplement some of the descriptions that
we use for
describing microbial pathogenesis
and todd's going to tell you more about
this in just a minute but i wanted to
mention that the
fun stock labels that we annotated
internally with our subject matter
experts were used for training and
testing of machine learning algorithms
within seek screen
so the
the experts that we have on our team
read scientific literature to assign fun
socks to different sequences
and so we have
experimental evidence for each of those
assignments
and then machine learning was used to
expand those fun stock labels to
all well-annotated proteins within
uniprot
and that is the database that you would
use with seek screen if you were to go
and download that today
and
one thing that i find helpful about that
approach compared to other approaches is
that
the the database that we have within c
screen contains very well annotated
sequences
so if you wanted to understand why
something was included
in our database and why it was given a
pathogenic label not only does it have a
fun stock label but it also has quite a
few gene ontology terms and other
annotations within uniprot that you
could go back and look at to try to
understand why it was classified in one
way or another
this is different than other databases
like the virulence factor database or
the vfdb
which does not include
information about why a sequence was
incorporated into their database so
there's no additional
metadata or ontology terms associated
with those sequences
and we feel like this is a strength of
our database because
that allows end users to help interpret
results uh with more confidence
so with that i'll wrap up and pass it
over to todd and todd i trust that you
are going to have fewer technical issues
than me
so
go for it
thanks krista um yeah that was uh um so
i'm just going to continue the
discussion um here and going to actually
do a
just a slightly more technical uh deep
dive into how do we computationally
detect these fun socks that were just
described
and so on your screen right now
we have just a toy example of an example
dna sequence frame fragment
and what i'm showing here is just to
convey the idea of what what is seek
screen doing well
when it's looking at this
example dna sequence fragment
essentially we want to identify
potentially fun sock containing regions
indicated in red
and for this mock example we have
cytotoxicity integrate ecm which are two
uh fun stocks
inside of the the total set
and then
we have a region in the middle that is a
housekeeping gene that has no fun socks
assigned
and so just conceptually here this is
again if we're thinking of what what
sequin is actually doing when it gets
handed a collection of dna sequence
fragments this is this is the task at
hand
but one question might be how does it
accomplish this
so
on on my next slide here this is going
back to what we saw previously
it's really this human and loop
fun sock prediction process
so
we started off with uh the biocreation
team
at signature science where
uh where they performed a
deep literature review uh reviewing
several relevant uh scientific
publications and sources of evidence for
placing specific uh sequences and
proteins uh into a given uh category of
a fund sock
from that we we
then used it developed a training uh
data set to train our machine learning
algorithm
to then go uh
and then apply that to uh
unseen sequences and and kind of iterate
over this process where where this is a
really key part of this whole project
and really require this uh
closely knit team effort over multiple
years where we would would annotate uh
through by expert biocuration
uh update our trainings that predict and
then hand that back to the via creation
team for review
and and and after doing that through
multiple iterations
we ended up with a software tool that
uh based that was closely vetted by by
the by creation experts but also um was
was built off of uh best practices in
terms of the machine learning side as
well
so
i have a couple just one uh next slide
is going to just get a little bit more
into the details of how did we train
seek scream
well without getting into too many
specific details which is outside of the
scope of today's presentation i would
just like to say that
we started off with a database of about
90 000 proteins which had high
confidence
annotations so for for training
and what what information is used for
training here it's going to be gene
ontology terms and keywords among other
features
and and and these are all these now all
have labels uh labeled with uh fun socks
uh
uh thanks to our bio creation uh team so
subset of vibration uh the label with
fun stocks and then we went out and and
trained and expanded this and for for
the iterative process i just described
so again without getting too much too
many details there are two different
machine learning
approaches one was where we actually
perform feature selection first and then
fun stock classification
and then one where we just uh given all
uh
the the after getting rid of the rare
features we just went straight into
funsock detection and again uh the the
manuscripts that at chris edge here
provide additional details in terms of
the specific machine learning approaches
that were used but needless to say there
was both feature selection based
approach and and just a a full set of
features where uh were used uh for the
fun stock detection and then again this
would tie into
the the iterative approach that was just
described
now
just high level uh i have a one figure
of results here uh x axis will indicate
one of the uh the the fun socks that
seek stream uh
detects or
classifies and and on the y-axis you
have kind of a
kind of an accuracy value
and and there's multiple colors lots of
rows all hard to read but the main
message here that
i would like to convey is there's
variable performance for any specific
machine learning approach for any
individual fun sock
however
if you look at the ensemble which is
where we combine multiple machine
learning approaches which is that red
line you will see that the performance
overall gets much more consistent across
all of the fun socks and these fun
stocks again referring back to my
original example could be
cytotoxicity could be antibiotic
resistance etc so
this slide is really to convey that seek
screen is is
uh has a
variable performance across any each
individual funds uh fund saw category uh
and we can we can help mitigate this by
using
an ensemble machine learning approach
built out by the team and that's the
main message for this slide
so now i just want to walk through two
vignettes before we conclude here
and really really just two quick
examples one is a near in neighbor
uh micro detection kind of example
and and vignette two is quote unquote a
needle in a haystack example so
uh just gonna walk through both of these
now so the first example is
we are the goal is let's say to identify
fun socks within a microbial clad with
with near neighbors and by near
neighbors i mean
a clay that contains
genomes that are
very similar to one another within one
or two percent average nucleotide
identity across the length of the genome
uh perhaps less perhaps slightly more
than that but more or less that's that's
the the framing of the problem
and to look at this uh we ran
state-of-the-art taxonomic classifiers
to to compare performance
um and then and then in this example
where we have a set of
very closely related genomes in this in
this case it is uh question bachelinum
with clostridiums
uh cyclin was able to correctly identify
fun socks associated with the body toxin
so i will walk through this now and then
result slide next and what do we have on
the screen on the top we have a table
that's that indicates for
two isolates the the near neighbor
microbe example that that uh
christians progenies and botulinum uh
top row is
c spo uh
bottom row c bot um any any red cell
will indicate the the column uh the
method indicated in the column uh
incorrectly labeled uh it was the other
uh genome
um and and anything in in in yellow is
indicating that it uh correctly labeled
it
and
and so
as we look across this uh we see
variable the main message here while is
is that you'll see variable uh kind of
performance across these the state of
the art taxonomic classifiers due to the
close closely related genomic content so
it's a very hard text taxonomic
classification task given these are all
very closely related and one could so so
the point of showing this to everyone is
is that
uh in this example what we really care
about is do these genomes uh contain a a
fun sock of concern or in this case the
bot can we identify the bot but a
protein
so so i i said previously that teaching
was able to but now what happens if we
remove the true organisms from the
database what if we remove the true
organisms and if we do that
some further confusion can happen with
the methods
and then what if what if on the secret
side we go remove all of the the
the c bot and the associated proteins
from the databases
um turns out that c screen is able to
identify a distant homolog uh that
uh and still
correctly identify fun sock containing
hits inside of the genome so this
example is a very short vignette into
16's ability to
characterize
fun-stock-containing sequences inside of
near-neighbor genomes which is a very
useful and important feature when you're
for for biosecurity analysis
for the next and final vignette i'm
going to talk about uh something called
the
needle in the haystack and what i mean
by this is really imagine imagine
someone there's a sample of millions or
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
of of sequences
and and say just a handful of those
are
contain
uh a fun sock or or sequence a function
a sequence of of concern here
and so we want to be able to uh
and even in those examples we don't we
don't want to uh
limit ourselves to only looking at
things that occur above a certain
frequency or a certain threshold we want
to be able to still even even in these
complex mixtures or
really high high high throughput data
sets still identify
a rare signal inside of that that sets
of
thousands tens of thousands millions
hundreds of millions of sequences
and this is exactly what 16 was able to
do so the
what
was what i'll now describe is
is the goal which is to find
differential genetology terms between
a control
and an equivalent 19 patient blood meta
transcriptome um so so we really want to
look and see so there's a
publicly available data we want you can
see screen find
any signal that would distinguish
between control
uh cover 19 negative and equivalent 19
positive
samples so three of each
in each category that could indicate the
presence of the the virus
and so um we ran an earlier version of
sikhstreen just to um simulate an
emerging pathogen example where where
the tsarskov2 gym was not in the in the
database um and and in this specific
case um uh the virus and case-specific
gene ontology terms were identified in
two reads uh in one of the cova-19
samples
and the gene ontology terms that were
associated with the
the differences
are listed here on the slide and i'm not
going to read the
you know them all out but essentially
they're all related to
suppression or induction of virus
activity uh which uh which corresponds
with um
later later uh we validated that you
know correspond to the stars kobe 2
activity so so uh this is just one
example again a second example of kind
of the utility of running seek green
in cases of
either
near neighbor pathogens or kind of
emerging pathogens in inside of uh
with kind of a trace signature
and just to visually show this again um
if we dig in further to this example uh
through
identifying these go terms specific to
the viral sequences
uh and and only finding two out of out
of uh
out of
many many reads uh this kind of
highlights the capability that secret
allows you to kind of pursue given that
it is an individual sequence
a
characterization tool will look at each
and every read within your sample
and try to assess uh the go terms and
the fun socks that that might be of uh
of interest with this with respect to
functions of sequences of concern
uh and on the slide here on the bottom
we're actually we if you pull the
if you pull the two reads out that we
identified uh we have a um
and we we highlight uh as fun saw
containing and of concern in the sample
they have uh perfect alignments to the
source cov22 genome so just as a as a
validation step here
with that um i would like to transition
um and kind of just summarize um
[Music]
on the next slide here um
so so
overall um
you know this
genome engineering holds great promise
and and also poses new biosecurity
considerations
and and not only with my colleagues uh
kristen beth but with
the
broader team and community
we need to proactively assess functional
impact of editing
um
uh inscript has prioritized biosecurity
it has a multi-pronged screening
approach uh very uh engaged with the
community we're very fortunate to be
collaborating within scripta on this
important problem
uh and and also
have long-standing partnership with the
signature science on this important
problem
and and just kind of summarizing some of
the points that were made earlier plus
in within my section
i just want to emphasize that sequin
provides an open source solution
uh to several genome engineering
sequence uh screening considerations and
and as was mentioned previously
um there are there this is not meant to
be uh replacing any any any tool this is
this is that was
identifying and feeling a need in a in a
use case that was previously unfilled we
we obviously appreciate all of the great
work that's been done in many many of
the areas we touched on
especially with respect to text on my
classification so
but the challenges remain um genomic or
original context context is not
accounted for and that's something that
needs to you know that would that would
help uh improve improve things more
um
there's there we need relevant test sets
of engineered sequences
uh we need improved buy risk relevant
annotation
and scale up continuing to making sure
that this can scale up is very important
so with that i would just kind of issue
a kind of a rallying call here for for
everyone uh
interested let's work together on this
important problem
um and then what i mean by that is
resource building and sharing
crowdsourcing and collaborative problem
solving there's a lot of potential here
there's a lot of room for collaborative
efforts on on this exciting yet and very
important problem
and and again just want to emphasize how
how great it's been to work with both in
scripta and signature science on this
problem
with that i would like to um
conclude just by acknowledging the great
team that has enabled all of all of the
the methods uh that were presented today
um
you know this that none none of this
happens without a a long-standing and
multi-year collaborative effort with
signature science
um they're they're we had a very uh just
vast team um uh i would like to shout
out to members uh
in my group specifically
uh invite philadelphia uh
geshe student in my group as well as uh
postdoctoral scientist uh dr leo elworth
who have contributed to previous
versions um and and and but also the
funding sources in the end users and the
broader microbial research and genome
engineering communities
we have
received so much valuable feedback and
important collaborations that have
helped improve this this open source
solution
uh
addressing this important need
and and we truly look forward to
continue working and engaging with with
all of you in the community
and again in terms of funding source
just just
one i want to acknowledge the support
that's been provided by ir bond of on
the fungicap program
over many years
and with that i would like to conclude
and and and and thanks again to my to uh
kristen bedford for setting setting up
my my section nicely and also thanks
everyone for attending today and happy
to to take any questions
and thank you todd and beth and krista
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion of
this webinar and if you have any
questions you want to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located at the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in from our
audience
our first question
is
seek screen is a reference database
dependent approach how does seek screen
behave if the dna sequence
being screened is a distant hit or no
hit to sequences
in its db
i could i could take that one that's a
that's a that's a great question um so
uh in the example i covered in in my
section uh
we it's important to note that
we uh took all of the
bot a toxins and and removed them all
from the database
and so it just exactly uh try to get
into that question we removed all
body toxins from the database and seek
screen was still able to identify a
distant homolog and then
characterize that as fun sock containing
so that answer is part of the problem
part of the question i'm sorry
kind of the second half of that question
um uh we we've used future work uh uh
the nova characterization approach for
sequences that are are just very distant
and have never been seen before
so so again um that we review that as
future work and happy to engage with
others as we move forward and kind of
look additionally into that area of kind
of de novo characterization of very
divergent previously unobserved
sequences
thank you so much our next question is
sequence screening against the database
done on the nucleotide or amino acid
sequence level
uh so i will take that um and that's a
great question um to maximize
sensitivity of the screening at the at
the genome level it's both nucleotide
and protein against the respective
databases um and and as the edit design
library uh
step um you know to receive screen it's
with six translation frames are all sent
through at the protein level um and this
facilitates prediction of the biological
significance as we heard from krista and
todd
thank you so much
now how does seek squeeze seek screen
work in relation to the igsc harmonized
screening protocol
yeah i can take a shot at that one and
others can chime in too thank you for
that question
so the the igsc harmonized screening
protocol focuses a lot on the list based
approach for screening as best and
others have mentioned today
and that has to do with looking at
b-stat agents and making sure that
the sequences that people are
going to synthesize don't match to
anything on that particular list
i think c-spring goes above and beyond
that list-based approach by looking at
the actual functional potential of
different sequences
and certainly we wouldn't want to
replace all the great work that has been
done in that protocol but we think that
these types of functional approaches
could be complementary and could help
enhance some of the insights
that companies can get when they're
screening sequences by looking at
functional potential
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in our next one how does
inscripta prevent misuse of the onyx
bench top um bio foundry
yeah so i'll interest that so that's the
you know the three levels of screening
um the customer screening up front um
and then the
um
you know the seeking screening also can
address that um we also have controls
within within the instrument um so to
prevent unauthorized use
um so yes it's all inherent within
the system
thank you so much
now is seek screens machine learning
approach supervised or unsupervised
learning
i can i could hop in and take that one
um so
uh it is a supervised human in the loop
machine machine learning approach um
and this is kind of a key aspect of
this this multi-year effort um
future work well we have have discussed
exploring unsupervised machine learning
approaches again to get uh to kind of
expand capabilities out but uh as is
it's the supervised machine learning
approach
thank you so much
our next audience member says i'm very
interested in contributing to the seek
screen code base how can i get involved
yeah i can take that one so so i
definitely encourage you to look at some
of the links that we had in our
presentation today to where you can find
our open source code
and
we encourage you to download and run our
software we also have an issues page on
our gitlab repository and you can post
any questions you have there or feature
requests that you might have in mind but
we're very happy to collaborate with
anyone who is interested so please do
reach out
to us through our software page
or to us directly and we'd be happy to
talk with you more about how we could
collaborate and get you plugged in and
involved in either seek screen software
or the larger genome engineering
biosecurity community
i guess just to add on that
i just want to emphasize the fact that
it is on gitlab and open source
just emphasize feature requests pull
requests comments
engage as as
engagement would be great
thank you so much chris and todd
we have time for a few more questions
our next question can interested
individuals become involved in the
ongoing genome engineering community
biosecurity dialogue and maybe
participate in future discussions
yeah i'll take that and absolutely
input and participation is welcome
so a step could be to contact one of the
event organizers of the workshop report
um or reach out to any of us um yeah
we're all we're happy for your input
from the entire community thank you
thank you so much beth our next question
where are the list of bad genes and
proteins you use for genome screening
coming from
um i will address that also um and is
this extends from chris's description of
the seek screen in relation to the igfc
protocol um so
all of inscriptive protocols you know
we've been also following and building
upon
um the harmonized protocol guidelines um
and they they follow hhs guidelines that
um we put out a few years ago for dna
synthesis providers so and we also we
leverage them and then extend upon them
um curating available databases and our
databases continue to evolve to meet
screening needs
so yeah that was a that was a good
question
thank you so much
what is the status of funding for seek
screen software development
yeah i can take that one so we are
currently funded through august of 2022
and that funding is primarily to help to
optimize seek screen analysis of long
reads
so that's with the ont mode that we
mentioned today
but we are actively interested in other
funding sources and other collaborations
so if you have an interest in continuing
to develop this software with us please
do reach out we would love to talk to
you more
that's krista todd i want to thank you
for your presentation today would you
like to provide any closing remarks
before we go
i don't think so other than thank you
all for for listening to us today and
participating and we hope to hear from
you and engage with you either on the
gitlab page or in other ways
in the future
well i want to thank you all three of
you again for your time today and for
your important research and i also want
to thank labruz and our sponsor in
scripta for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to remind our audience and thank
them for joining us today and for the
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand laborats
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
bye
you